[Music]  you've been  in a terrible accident  i'm dr kafka i'm here to help you  of course you are doc that's why you're  preparing military-grade  biostem electrodes high-intensity  capacitors  the kind to make an escort all of this  cause you're trying to help me you are  correct  i'm here to study you to understand  what you are why  you are i will get results  i always do  you do realize you locked me in a prison  that runs out on electricity  i can feel it in my walls  no matter what you do duck you can't  contain it  it's a force of nature like me  you want to know how powerful i am yeah  well so do i  uh  but you better make damn sure you kill  me this time  cause if you don't i'm gonna kill  the light everyone in the city is gonna  know how it feels  to live in my world a world without  power  a world without mercy a world  without spider-man and everyone will be  able to see me  for who i truly am and who  are you don't you know  very impressive electric truck  you